the superintendent of Yosemite National  Park had to resign amidst accusations of  sexual harassment  now it's terrible to hear but he's not  the only national parks employee who's  been accused of harassment towards women  this is sad hi kids I'm Smokey Bear what  things can cause a wildfire I'll tell  you smokin hot babes  I had this babe up in my cave last  weekend and she had the most perfect ass  anyway we need to protect the woods  speaking of wood I've got some wood in  my pants just thinking about that ass  see what I mean if you find matches or a  lighter what should you do that's right  take it to your mom Kyle is your mom a  squirrel because she's all over my nuts  lately  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you